who are you excited to see tonight um
so many people i i was just saying i'm
excited to see olivia
i love her she's the best you guys are
such young powerhouses who have
the brightest futures in this industry
do you guys lean into each other with
that
yeah i mean we're we're good friends and
she's honestly like it's cool because
it's someone i can like talk to and
relate to
i feel like we're just like the same age
going through the same so it's like
we're just like are able to connect on
that level and that's really nice what
is some of that same ish that you guys
are going through obviously being so
young in the industry and then coming
into this industry and kind of
dominating the way you have with your
music what is some of the stuff you're
going through i mean i think both of us
are perfectionists so it's like put it
you put your own pressure on yourself
and so both of us like want to be the
best we can be and i think that's like
for an 18 year old it's a lot and we're
like constantly just like wanting things
to be perfect so i think that's
something that we like relate over who
are some of your mentors in the business
because at 18 you need some solid ones
yeah i mean i've met a lot of amazing
like songwriters and producers
but usually it's like keeping your like
family close
because like there's so many people in
the industry it's like the people that
know you the best are the ones who are
going to like always be there for you so
i think it's just like my mom and dad
who are like mentoring me through
everything i'm sure they're so proud
what is next for you
i mean i just released my first single
of my debut album last week and i'm
working on my mom like what's next honey
keep it going keep it going you're like
ma'am calm down i'm about to do jingle
bell tour
um
and then i'm touring all year next year
and then going on tour sean mendes
so oh my god wait i'm so sad about the
breakup i am i am devastated because
they were the cutest couple ever oh my
god can we all mourn together it's a
good thing adele just dropped a new
album oh thank god she's she's helping
us all right now how do you think
shawn'll bounce back quickly i don't
know i mean they were like they were
like really close i thought so
i mean it's like every couple goes
through it and i feel like they're just
gonna
take their time unfortunately that is
the part of like it's just the crappy
part of life and i mean we're all
heartbroken that's the thing you have
like millions of other people who are
heartbroken with you
and as an artist you all get to write
about it now and then turn it into hits
oh i know he's gonna have a crazy
breakup album
gotta prepare for that one jesus it's
gonna be crazy